the teenager is in custody after he  jumped out of an airplane while it was  taxing to the gate cell phone video  shows passengers in shock moments after  the 17 year old American opened an  emergency exit and slid off the wing the  plane had just landed in San Francisco  passenger said the teen was anxious and  fidgety during the flight from Panama he  was traveling alone we just landed and  then I hear some people like scream like  you'll know and then this guy I see him  jump on the wing and then he starts  climbing down the wing and then he just  runs and then he just starts running the  other way a construction crew detained  the teen as he tried to run away he  wasn't injured but he was taken to the  hospital for a psychiatric evaluation  customs and border control are  investigating